[Music]
forced marriage child marriage these are
real problems here in the United States
and nobody else is paying any attention
to this
why we like to think of the United
States as being far advanced when it
comes to women's rights and girls rights
but in the decade 2000 to 2010 almost a
quarter of a million children were
married in the United States and nobody
was talking about this somebody needed
to do something I stepped up because I
have been through it myself and I wanted
to help
I grew up in the ultra-orthodox Jewish
community which is a very insular
religious community I always knew that I
would marry young and it would be a
marriage that would be arranged for me
I was a clueless 19 year old I was so
happy on my wedding day I was doing
everything that I had always been told I
wanted to do and then it took exactly
one week for that all to come crashing
down my then-husband flew into this you
know violent rage and then he threatened
to kill me for the first time it was a
reality check for me you know it's it's
painful but yeah hey you go through it
was part of what makes you who you are I
finally put a plan in place to get out
when I was 27 because at that point
things I gotten so bad so it was a
five-year escape plan it was terrifying
and so lonely and there was no one who
supported me everyone I knew had
declared me dead and everyone in the
outside world could not possibly
understand this process that I was going
through but I got divorced and I was
able to rebuild my life from scratch
there are so many other women and girls
who end up getting stuck in an abusive
relationship and I thought I need to
help them get to where I was able to get
somehow I'm sure that last is the only
organization that is dedicated to ending
force and child marriage in the United
States through direct services and
through advocacy so the first thing that
we do when if somebody reaches out to us
for help is we make sure that they are
someplace safe
coordinating escapes is one of the key
services that we provide we provide free
legal representation through our team of
pro bono attorneys and they'll provide
emotional support and anything else to
these women there are many many
different reasons that parents will
force an adult or a minor child to marry
certainly culture religion tradition you
know was one of those reasons but it's
not the only one for example you know a
child comes out as LGBTQ or a girl gets
pregnant when the family says we're
gonna respond to this with a forced
marriage I mean this is not just
happening in any one community
I grew up with a very abusive father he
wanted me to be with someone he could've
control and if it weren't for fraidy I
would probably be living a very
different life and an arranged marriage
Freddie is the most compassionate gentle
sensitive person and she will keep
fighting for you even when you lose the
fight when you feel like you have no
fight left inside yourself she's
actually making a difference and
spreading awareness in a way that can
save so many people from going through
the experiences that I went through I
found that Unchained in 2011
since then we have helped about 500
people to escape forced marriages but
more and more girls under 18 we're
reaching out to ask for help and we
realize under 18 there's almost nothing
legally that we can do to help these
girls really the only way to help them
is to change the laws in many states the
loopholes in their marriage age laws
were so gaping that they didn't specify
any minimum age for marriage thanks to
your leadership were really really
hopeful that we can finally end child
marriage in the United States we finally
had our first victory Delaware became
the first US state to end child marriage
and then soon thereafter New Jersey
became the second state no marriage
before age 18 we're using the democratic
process we are raising awareness and
we're meeting with legislators one at a
time and we hold these chain ends that's
a form of protest that we invented where
we gather and we all wear Braille gams
and veils and we chained our wrists to
show legislators this is what life looks
like for a girl or a woman who was
forced to marry
[Music]
every time I'm able to help somebody
who's going through what I went through
that that never gets old that feeling
it's so healing and empowering
[Music]
and for all those that I couldn't help
especially the the children those under
18 who there was nothing that we could
do um passing those laws to end child
marriage it's a you know my message to
dam up I'm sorry I couldn't help you but
this will never happen again at least in
this state
[Music]
until I am too old to wear my Hills
anymore and too old to put on my red
lipstick in the morning I am going to be
still fighting to end forced and child
marriage in the United States still
helping the individuals who are affected
by it and still pushing for policy
change and legal change and we're not
giving up
you
you